hi there welcome to this new learning
series called I am and servers and AWS
for security by the way I'm Samuel and
AWS cloud architect cloud events listed
cloud author working for simply long
here in this section we're gonna talk
about what is security in AWS and then
we're going to slowly or gradually move
on to the other topics like types of
security available on AWS out of all the
services why I am is the most preferred
one and then we're gonna talk about what
is I am in general how it works the
building blocks are components in I am
and the features it the attractive
features that it provides that makes I
am stand out from the rest of the
services available we're going to talk
about that and then we're gonna end
today's session with a demo about how I
am gets well interacted with other
services in Amazon and help create a
secure environment in the cloud let's
talk about aw security now cloud
security is the highest priority in AWS
and when we host our environment in the
cloud we can be rest assured that we are
hosting our environment in a data center
or in a network architecture that's
really built to meet the requirement of
the most security sensitive organization
and this high level of security is
available to us on a pay-as-you-go type
meaning there is really no upfront cost
at that we need to pay and the cost for
using the service is lot lot cheaper
than what it is in an on-premises
environment so AWS cloud provides an
secure virtual platform where we can
deploy our application now compared to
the on-premises with AWS the security
level is very high and the cost involved
in using or attaching that type of
security to our application is very low
compared to on-premises does really no
upfront cost and the cost is very lower
whatever cost that we pay is very lower
than what it would be in our premises
and
all this contributes to the secure
environment we can get through I am in
AWS cloud there are really many types of
security services available in AWS to
name a few or to name the familiar ones
I am stands first followed by a key
management system kms and then we have
Cognito that's another service and web
access firewall väth is another security
service in AWS now let's start our
discussion by talking about I am and
that's what this whole series is about
now I am or identity and access
management it really enables us to
manage access to AWS services and AWS
resources in a very secure manner with I
am we can create groups we can actually
allow those users or groups to access
some servers or we can sort of deny them
to access the service which we want
that's all possible through Identity and
Access Management and this feature comes
with no additional charge let's talk
about how things were before
AWS before AWS or before I am in general
it was not that safe in a corporate to
share the password over the phone or
through the email that was the practice
that was existed at that time now we all
can remember the days when we need to
switch to a different account or we had
just one admin password commonly stored
in a location or one person would reset
it and maintain it at any time or we
need to login we call the person ask for
the admin password over the phone and
then we try logging in that was not
secure at all back that no somebody
could walk by and sort of eavesdrop you
know get the password now they walk away
with the password with them so they're
all possible when we share the password
over the phone and through the internet
or email
now with AWS a lot of options are
available that I'm not sharing password
over the unsecure medium now a slack is
a third party product available with AWS
it's not an AWS product but slack is in
third party application that's hosted on
AWS and it's really a communication tool
that helps people to share a document so
now we're not sharing
the password over the forum rather
through the applications and no
eavesdrop person can really catch the
password and you know tried in their
system to access our environment that's
not possible so you see the difference
now back then sharing password was only
through phone and email and you would
write it on a paper and he gave it to
somebody but now technology is providing
provisions enough for us to share the
password in a secure way we're still
talking about I am I am as an web
servers for securely controlling access
to the AWS resource now it really helps
us to authenticate our sort of limit
access to a certain set of users
accessing the AWS account or certain set
of users accessing a certain set of
resources in AWS account now you see
this picture we have an I am
administrator who's trying to allocate
permissions to different group of people
so we have Group one on the top and blue
two in the middle and Group three
towards the end the administrator using
I am or I am empowers the administrator
al of access to certain group to certain
resources that's what I am is all about
now let's talk about the building blocks
or let's talk about the elements that
make and complete I am so the elements
are categorized into six different
elements we have the principal in I am
the authentication they request the
actual request coming in the
authorization allowing denying access
actions what are the scope of actions
can be taken and on what resource is it
easy to is it
RDS is an s3 bucket so what resource
these actions are applied to so they are
the basic elements of an I am workflow
let's talk about principle for example
an action on AWS resource can only be
performed by a principle an individual
user they can be a principle a role in
AWS I am it can be a principle as well
in other words a principle as an entity
that can take an action on an AWS
resource you know a principle can be an
user a principle can be a role a
principle can be an application that's
are trying to access the AWS can
and secondly authentication of
authentication is a process of
confirming the identity of the principal
trying to access the AWS environment now
how do we get authenticated or how does
the user get authenticated by providing
credentials or the required keys to
validate that this is what he or she is
as for what's in the record so all
principal must be authenticated and we
get authenticated using the username and
password to log into the console if it
is CLI or we get authenticated using the
access key and the secret access key the
other component that makes up I am is
request when a principal tries to use
the AWS management console what the
principal is doing or what the user is
doing is sending a request to the AWS
environment and the request will have
the principal actually wants to perform
is it and put requests or is it a get
request or is the delete request stuff
like that and it's also going to carry
information about on which resource and
the action needs to be done is it on ec2
one is it on s3 buckets simply long comm
stuff like that so it has a specific
action that it wants to perform and the
resource on which it wants to perform
and also some information about from
where the request is originating from is
it within an ADA blazing with almond or
is it with another cloud service
provider or is it with on-premises stuff
like that so these information will be
present in the request authorization now
this I am uses information from the
request context at the check for
matching policies and it determines it
takes a decision whether to allow are to
deny the request now here it has a logic
by default all the resources are denied
and I am authorizes you request only if
every part of the request is allowed by
a matching policy so there's an
evaluation logic and that says but
default all requests are denied and if
there is an explicit allow then it
overrides the default denied and if you
are explicitly denying a service then
all the allow statements gets overridden
and all the other statements gets over
return and this explicit denied stance
by default on
the AWS account root user has access to
all the resources in that account so if
you're not signed in as a root user then
we must be specifically granted
permission through a policy in other
words we need to be authorized through
the policy now let's talk about action
now after authenticating and authorizing
the request AWS approves the action that
we are about to take now I'm using
action we can view the content we can
create a content or create a bucket or
create an ec2 instance I can edit
content or even I can delete a resource
that's all based on the action that I'm
allowed to do now that was about actions
now where is the action performed the
action is performed kondal sources a set
of actions can be performed on a
resource and anything that's not
mentioned in the action or anything
that's not tagged with the action and
the resource they don't get to complete
for example let's say if you attempt to
delete and I am role and you also
request to access the ec2 instance for
that role then the request gets denied
now let's talk about some of the other
components of I am so the other
components are I am are the basic
building block is an user and then many
users together they form a group and
then policies are the engines that
allows or denies a connection based on
policy one gets to access or gets no
access to a resource and then roles
roles are another component roles are
temporary credentials I would say that
can get assumed to an instance as and
when needed let's talk about this
component called user in an I am with I
am we can securely manage access to AWS
services and how we can create an IM
user anytime there is a new employee
joining our cartridge so it's a
one-to-one mapping you know one user or
one employee get a user name directly
attached to them and a user name or a
user is an account specific thing you
know it's very local to that AWS account
that we are using so for in detail and I
am user is an entity that we create in
an AWS environment to
and a person are a service and that
interacts with AWS environment and this
user is going to have some credentials
attached to them and by default they do
not have a password and they do not have
any access key or secret access key
attached to them
in fact literally no credentials of any
kind no we must create an user and we
must create the type of credential that
gets attached to the user do they want
to access CLI so based on that we would
be adding credentials to them a user by
default is not authorized to perform any
action in AWS and the advantage of
having one-to-one user is that we can
assign permissions individually to that
user for example we might want to assign
administrative permissions to few users
who can administer our AWS environment
and users our entity within an AWS
account users don't have to pay
separately you know they start using the
servers and that get bills under the
account they are attached to so separate
users doesn't mean that separate payment
for those users they are just users in
our account and you know the whole
account gets to pay for the resources
that they provision again the I am user
does not always represent a person and I
am user is really just an identity with
associated credential and permissions
attached to it it could be an actual
person who is a user and it could be an
application also who is a user next we
will talk about groups talking about
groups or understanding group is very
easy a collection of user forms and I am
group and we can use iam group to
specify permission for multiple user so
that any permission that's applied to
the group is also applied to the users
who are at add to that group now there
are a few things you might want to know
about group a group can have many users
and a user they can belong to many
groups but groups can be nested meaning
group can only have users a group cannot
have a group inside a group that's not
possible
and there's nothing called a default
group that sort of automatically
includes all users in the AWS account if
you want to have a group
we will have to create a group now let's
take this diagram for example now this
is a diagram of an small company now the
company owner creates an admin group for
users to create and manage other users
as the company expands every day and the
admin group creates a developer group
and a test group each of these group
consists of users users who are people
users who are applications that interact
with AWS environment so the different
types of users we have our Jim is a user
Brad is an user and dev app one is a
user and and so on
so each users have an individual set of
security credential like I said it's
one-to-one and the ten users that we see
on screen are shared between our they
belong to multiple groups in the account
and managing group is quite easy we said
permission to the group and that
permission gets applied to all the users
automatically in the group and after we
applied the policy if I add another user
to the group the new user will
automatically inherit all the policies
all the permissions that's already
mentioned in that group so
administrative burden is sort of taken
away administrative burden about user a
privilege or user permission management
is sort of taken out with I am alright
the next thing we will want to discuss
this policy a policy sets permission and
controls the access to AWS resource and
the policies this permissions and
controls are stored in JSON format a
policy is very clear document it defines
who has access to a resource and what
are all the actions they can perform so
in other words policy is an entity in
AWS that when a policy gets attached to
an identity or resource you know it
really defines the permission what they
can and cannot do and AWS it evaluates
these policies when a principle such as
a user makes an a request and the
permission statement and the policy it
really defines whether the user is
allowed to access a service or easy
denied to access a service or a let
take this example now we have task the
task is to give Paul who's a developer
access to Amazon s3 environment and what
you're looking at is a snippet of what a
policy would look like so these are some
questions we will have to answer or
these are some question the policy tries
to answer and once it found an answer
then it becomes incomplete policy so who
wants access to the service it's Paul
who wants access to the service and what
action do Paul want now Paul wants to
download or Paul wants to upload objects
in s3 in JSON language it's otherwise
called Paul wants to get information
Paul wants to put information otherwise
Paul wants to get object Paul wants to
put object in s3 and which resource does
he want now in this case every bucket
the star symbol represents all buckets
in history so which resource it's all
bucket in history so we can start
reading already from the data present
here so who wants access Paul wants
exits what action does he want he wants
to get he wants to put and what's the
resource that he's trying to access or
you want to give him access it's all the
bucket in AWS and when does he want
these an additional statement that goes
in a policy so since when does he want
that access he wants access till March
2nd 2019 so all this who all this action
all this resource you know till the time
all this gets allowed so this is the
statement that really defines now this
is all refer to an allow statement or
does this all refer to a deny statement
if we had denying here it's the direct
opposite of what we discussed but we
have allow that means Paul is allowed to
get and put access in an s3 bucket and
all the buckets in s3 till March 2nd
2019 he's allowed to access the
resources so if we put together put all
the information that we have gathered or
all the answers that we have so far if
we put together in a JSON format this is
how it's gonna look like so the effect
is allow or deny here it's allowing and
the principle is any who can access it's
any and action it's any bucket in s3 any
action in Esther day put get requests
and the resources any bucket in s3 so
that's how a basic policy would look
like that's how a basic policy is formed
by answering those basic questions so
let's talk about the types of policies
so we have two broad categories manage
policy and inline policy the manage
policy it's the default policy that we
attach to multiple entries bead users
feed groups and lead roles in our AWS
account on the other hand inline policy
are the policies that we create and
manage them and these policies are
embroidered directly into a single user
group or a role so if I need to brief it
a little bit more then a manage policies
our standalone identity based policies
that we can attach to multiple users
groups and roles in our AWS account we
can use two types of managed policies in
other words manage policies they
themselves have do categories one is AWS
manage for a C's which is created and
managed by a lab Rios and the other one
is customer manage policies just like
the name says it's managed by the
customer now we can create an edit and I
am policy in visual editor or simply
create a JSON policy document directly
and uploaded in the console and start
using them so that's manage policy on
the other hand inline policies are
policies that we create and manage and
that are embedded directly into a single
user group or role let's talk about this
next component called role now this role
is very similar to everything that we
discussed so far it's a self permission
that defines what actions are allowed
and denied by an entity in an AWS
console the role is very similar to an
user I said very similar I didn't say
it's the same as the user but I said
it's very similar to the user and the
difference is that user is hard-coded
user permissions are hard-coded but the
role permissions are accessed by any
entity you know beat a user or a beat
and AW service and moreover the role
permissions are temporary on the other
hand user permissions are permanent and
the role permissions are temporary
so in detail
a roll is very similar to a user in that
it's an edible identity with permission
policies that determines what the
identity can and cannot do in AWS now
instead of it being uniquely associated
with one person a role is intended to be
assumable by anyone who needs it rules
generally do not have an long-term
credential you know password or access
Keys associated with it you know it does
not have long-term credentials it only
has temporary credentials created
dynamically and provided to the user as
in when the user assumes a role and
wants to access any service roles can be
assumed by users roles can be assumed by
applications roles can be assumed by
services that normally they don't have
access to AWS resources for example you
might want to grant a user in your AWS
account access to your resource that
they do not normally have our grant
users in one aw account access to
resource in another AWS account now this
is something that we don't have by
default and this is something we may not
need all the time or you might want to
allow a mobile app to use AWS resource
but you do not want to save the key or
save the credential or save the
passwords in the mobile app or sometimes
you might want to give access to
resources who already have identities
defined outside of AWS like a user who's
already an Google or Facebook
Authenticator if you want to give them
some service or if you want to let them
to access some of the resources in your
account we can use roles for that
purpose or you also might want to grant
access to your account to a third party
a consultant or an auditor so they can
for some time get some temporary access
to audit our AWS resources remember
they're not permanent users it's just
temporary users they want some temporary
access to our environment till the audit
is over so for those cases roles are a
very good use case so let's take this
example let's see where role sits and
let's see how roles give permission to
other services so here is a scenario
where we're an easy-to instance
once access to an s3 bucket but default
though both of them were created by the
same username are the same admin they do
not have access by default so by default
they don't have access and I also do not
want to give permanent access you know
one on one hot coded permanent access
instead I would like to create and share
access so that's possible through role
so coming back to the discussion the
scenario here is that an ec2 instance
wants to access data in an s3 bucket so
the first thing is to create a role or a
permission we saw how that's done right
using policies roles use policies policy
is the actual working engine for any
permission related actions right so
create a role with an appropriate policy
that gives access to s3's
bucket and then launch an ec2 instance
with the role attached to it
we said roles are assumed by any entity
right it could be user it would be an
application it could be a service it
could be another resource in AWS account
so here it's another resource in AWS
account right so we create a role and we
attach it to an ec2 instance so now the
easy to instance can assume the role now
the same role can be attached to another
ec2 instance the same role can be
attached to another user the same role
can be attached to another database
service we get the idea right roles can
be assumed by anyone so when the ec2
instance want to communicate with s3 it
contacts the role and then the role
gives this ec2 instance some temporary
username and password that expires after
one our let's say so it's a temporary
username and password now with that
temporary username and password the ec2
instance can access the s3 bucket and
access the file with the credential that
it already has and that credential is a
temporary one and the credential will
expire after one our or how much
overtime the admin sets it to be and
then the next time when s when an ec2
instance wants to contact this three
it'll have to contact the role and the
role will propose a new access key and
secret access key in other words a new
credential with that new credential
the second time the ec2 instance will be
able to contact the s3 bucket and get
the information so the password is not a
permanent or a one-time or a hard-coded
password it keeps rotating it's a token
it's a secure token that an ec2 instance
or any application that uses the rule
gets to access the resources on the
other end now let's talk about the
features of I am the main feature of iam
is that I can create separate username
and password for individual users or
resources and I can delegate access know
those days where we had just one
username and password for admin and we
need to call the other person to get the
username and password over the phone if
it gets compromised
you know the whole account gets
compromised stuff like that those issues
are gone I can create separate username
and password for all thousand users in
my account
no more username and password sharing I
can manage access to all those thousand
accounts and a very simple and an easy
way so I am provides shared access for
all the thousand users in my account it
provides share access to the AWS
environment and the permissions that can
be given through I am are very granular
now we saw how restrictions can be put
on get requests you know we can allow
the user to download information and not
update an information so that's possible
through the IM policies that we looked
at some time back and with the use of
roles you know we're authenticating an
ec2 instance instead of
the application running on top of it so
if there are like 10 or 20 applications
running on top of an ec2 instance
instead of creating a separate username
and password for all those twenty
instances I can create a role and assign
that role to the ec2 instance and all
the applications running on the ec2
instance get a secure access to the
other resources use the role potential
that's provided to that ec2 instance
now besides username and password I am
also supports multi-factor
authentication where we provide our
credential the username and password
plus and OTP from our phone or and
randomly generated number that gets
displayed in our phone before Amazon
console or
before Amazon CLI would authenticate and
lets us access some of the service in
the account so it's called multi-factor
authentication its username and password
plus something else from what you have I
am also provides identity Federation if
the user is already authenticated with a
corporate ad or Facebook or Google you
know I am can be made to trust that
authentication method and then allow
access based on that authentication now
without the Federation what would happen
is the users will have to remember two
passwords you know one for on-premises
and one for cloud anytime they work on
on-premises they'll have to use one set
of password and any time they switch to
the cloud which is gonna be very
frequent in a everyday so anytime they
switch to the cloud they will have to
again type in the cloud username and
password now with identity Federation we
can sort of Fed rate or we can connect
both the authentication systems both
on-premises and I am so users can just
use one username and password for both
on-premises and cloud environments and
all that we saw so far it's free to use
there is no additional charge for I am
security there is no additional charge
for creating additional users groups or
policies it's a free service comes along
with any account I am is an PCI DSS
compliant product and I am consulate
password policy where we can reset the
password remotely or rotate the
passwords remotely and we can set rules
like and how a user should pick and
password it should not be the one that
was used in the past any of the past
three times stuff like that so you get
the idea right how the features of I am
helped us to build and a secure
authentication and authorization system
in our for our AWS account alright it's
time to do a quick lab let's let's put
all the knowledge that we have earned so
far together and apply it and try a lab
and solve the problem so here is a
problem statement we need to create an
s3 bucket for a company where users can
read or write the data only if they are
multi-factor
indicated so that could be like 20 users
in an account but a user is allowed to
read or write a data in an s3 bucket
only if the user is multi-factor
authentication you know this is a very
good use case if we have sensitive data
in an s3 bucket and you only want
privileged or MFA authenticated users to
do changes to those buckets and for
those privileged users you would enable
multi-factor authentication so let's see
how that's done before that let me talk
to you a bit more about multi-factor
authentication a multi-factor
authentication is that additional level
of security process it's provided by AWS
here the user's identity is confirmed
only after the user proposes or the user
passes to level of verification now one
being the username and password and
another being and OTP that gets
generated in this case it's the mobile
phone it could also be an RSA token key
that generates the one-time password
that's possible as well but in this case
it's the mobile phone now that's gonna
be very similar to how we login to our
gmail account sometimes when we log into
a gmail account and I mean if you have
the proper setting enable it's gonna
send and one-time password to the mobile
phone and only after we put that
information it's gonna let us login
let's see how all this is done in an AWS
account so the first thing is to log in
to the AWS account create a user and
attach the user to the virtual MFA
device now we're gonna use Google
Authenticator here and we're gonna
attach the user to Google Authenticator
and make the user use the Google
Authenticator one-time password every
time he logs in to the account now this
is an addition to the username and
password that he or she already has
right so the first thing is to log into
the account connect or sync the virtual
appliance with the AWS username and
password now when we think there will be
an one time password that gets shown in
the phone type in the password in the
AWS console and in the phone and the
user name comes to same and from that
point onwards the user any time they log
in they will have to propose their
username and password which is the first
step of security and there
once they typed in the username and
password type in the MFA code that gets
generated on the phone that would be the
second step or security or the last step
of security once that is done the
account is gonna let them log in and
access the AWS resources alright so in
order to test I am
MFA s3 together this is what we're gonna
do so we're gonna create a bucket and
we're gonna have two users and we're
gonna allow or deny access to the s3
bucket to those two users based on
whether they are MFA authenticated or
not and on purpose we gonna assign MFA
to one user and no I'm afraid to the
other user like you might have guessed
by now the user with MFA will have
access to their bucket and the user with
no MFA attached will not have access to
the bucket and both of them are gonna
have full s3 services but MFA like I
said is one layer above the other
permissions Emma Fame stands at all time
so irrespective of whether the
underlying policy says but they have
full access to the s3 bucket they are
not going to because MFA stands on top
of it let's see how that's done to begin
with firstly we need a bucket so let's
create a bucket so I'm in my AWS console
so let me go to s3
and in here create a bucket call that
bucket as simply learn MF a bucket and
let me put it in not Virginia and create
alright so that's done now I'm gonna put
a separate folder in here
I'm going to create another folder in
here and the name of the folder is tax
documents now this is where I'm planning
to keep my tax files
my privileged users to be able to upload
and download information from the tax
document so on the bucket side it's
partially done or on the SD side it's
partially done so let's go back to I am
and here are we're gonna create two
users one a junior employee and another
one and a senior employee the senior
employee is the one who's gonna have MFA
access and more access to the s3 bucket
and the junior employee is the one who's
not gonna have access to that particular
bucket so let's get started let's create
an user under I am
click on users and let's create a user
call his user jr. right so he's a junior
user and for the password set a password
the user does not need to create a new
password at sign-in because it's a test
environment and the user who creates the
username and the user are the same
person
so let's keep it simple username
password management console access and
this user is gonna have full s3 bucket
access all right this is really the
policy we should be familiar
would this DSN document by now it says
effect is allow and what action any
action in destiny and what resource
anybody who's attached to it review and
create a user so this user is having s3
full access now let's create another
user call them as senior employee
all right attach a policy to the user
you know from the surface level both of
them have the same permissions both of
them have s3 full access
all right so both of them have s3 full
access as we see there's one thing
different we're gonna do to this senior
employee now we're going to attach MFA
to this implant so the way we would do
it is under the summary section of that
particular user click on security
credential and see here is a place we
can attach an MFA to this user
so let's attach MFA to this user for MFA
I can use both virtual MFA or Hardware
MFA this being in lab environment we're
gonna use virtual MFA now that is an
application there are a lot of
applications available but there is one
application that I'm using at the moment
called Google Authenticator
so once we have installed the
application and once it is running
so I can go to what she will MFA device
and once it is running I can scan the
code using the Gulag or Authenticator in
my mobile phone once you turn on the
application and I want to do scan the
barcode that is showing right here now
that's gonna give us codes that we can
use and we will have to put in those
codes here twice we'll have to wait for
some time and it would generate and
second set of key that we can put so my
first set of key is 4 0 2 3 5 1 right
I'll have to wait for some time and then
it would throw me a second set of key
it's like validating twice right here so
let me put on my second set of key
so this user is now MFA authenticated
user so anytime this user logs in it's
gonna ask for MFA anytime this user
proposes something it's going to attach
the MFA key along with it all right so
we're done with the I am what have you
done what I am we have created two users
both of them have a safe Alexis but one
of them have MFA access and the other
one does not have MFA access and based
on whether the user is having MFA or not
you know we're identifying privileged
users by this MFA alright so based on
whether the user has MFA or not are we
gonna allow deny access in the s3 bucket
so we already have a bucket we already
have a folder and this is a very
privileged folder pod here I would like
to restrict access based on whether the
user is having MFA or not so let me
create a bucket policy here
now here's a policy that I have written
the policy says that you know under tax
document folder give access only if the
user is MFA authenticated right if the
user is not MFA authenticated simply
deny the access to that user so as you
might guess right now the user one will
not have access or the junior employee
will not have access because it's a
privilege then you know junior employee
might tend to delete them unknowingly
and only privileged users get access to
the tax document because it's
confidential because it's privileged
because if it gets deleted we won't be
able to get it back for those reasons
right so apply the bucket policy
not try logging in as the different
users and see how the permissions are
applied on both the users all right so
let's make a note of the I am URL
and then the 2 usernames and password
let's login
so let me log in as the privileged user
sure enough I'm being asked for an MFA
code let me put my MFA code
so let's directly navigate to the s3
bucket right here is my privileged path
let me try uploading some content claim
forms
sure enough I'm able to upload content
into it will I be able to delete
yes unable to delete as well now let's
see what's the situation for the other
user so let's login as the other user
navigate to the SD bucket
if you noticed when logging in it did
not ask for an mfa code because the user
is not set up for MFA so navigate to the
folder which we want to test
I'll try adding some files
as you see it's failing to add content
into this bucket it shows error because
the bucket policy is requiring MFA and
this user is not MFA and we did that in
I am or under I am but still as you see
you know they will be able to view the
content in the bucket they can do all
that we have specifically restricted
access to upload and download content
from the bucket and that's exactly this
user is now denied with all right let's
summarize what did we learn we began our
discussion with types of AWS security
available with I am you know key
management system cognitive web access
firewall and then we started our
discussion or and then we went deep into
the discussion about I am identity and
access management and then we discussed
about the different components present
and I am that's users group policies and
rows and we discussed about all of them
in detail and we also looked at the
features of I am feature of I am is
being able to have a share access to an
account granular permissions being able
to provision or provide granular
permissions being able to are providing
an application a secure access to the
other AWS resources and being able to
attach multi-factor authentication to an
IM user that's something we discussed as
features of I am and then we did a lab
on s3 where we had to user 1 user was
privileged over the other I mean we were
allowing denying connection based on
whether the user is MFA authenticated or
not I mean if I need to tell clearly we
allowed or we denied editing a file or
uploading a file to a particular folder
based on whether the user is an MFA
authenticated user or not and that
folder is a very critical folder we
cannot afford to have any junior
employee delete any content or upload a
wrong content in it by mistake that's
what we saw I believe you really enjoy
the session along with me we will meet
you again in another similar learning
video till then stay tuned and bye for
now
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos sinnard up and get certified
click here